all right time to talk to one of our
favorite players in the national
football league and also he has been
named the bearded old spice guy he's
joining us thanks to the new old spice
beard care collection designed to help
guys achieve the soft nourished and
sculpted beard of their dreams available
exclusively on amazon.com he is chief's
tight end travis kelsey i notice the
beard is starting to creep down a little
bit farther and farther how are you
going for his easy top thing
oh yeah i mean i'm going as big as i can
as i can get it right now it's uh it's
it's fun to maintain it's fun to
maintain a beard now
how do you how do you reconcile the long
beard with a chin strap because i see
ryan fitzpatrick i see eric weddle now
we're going to see you how how do you
stay comfortable in your uniform when
all this hair is hanging down under your
chin strap
um i don't know i'm not gonna lie i
really don't i don't notice it i don't
recognize it i i when i'm out there
playing as soon as i put as soon as i
strap up it's uh it's game on and i'm
not really thinking about my beard i
don't know it
it sounds funny but i guess it uh
especially when you're grooming it right
it's not itchy it's not
annoying or anything like that you could
just kind of just let it let it flow
you know it's one it's one with the
helmet
there have been questions about pulling
a guy's hair from behind and we've seen
it before and it's actually not a
penalty you you can't pull a guy down by
his hair from the back i guess we now
have to consider the possibility of a
guy getting pulled down by his hair from
the front if someone tackles you by your
beard would that be enough to get you to
trim it back
um maybe just a little bit yeah just
when it's hanging out and guys can can
get a good grasp of it i think that's uh
that might be the limit like all right
when i was getting a little too big for
me
speaking of getting a good grasp you had
a heck of a catch over the weekend one
of the best of the year so far the
one-hander against the 49ers for you on
your personal all-time greatest catches
list where does that rank
um
it's probably got to be one of the one
of the better catches i've ever had i
mean it's uh
it was kind of a it was it was a bang
bang play i kind of i just put my hand
out there and tried to snag it um
but it i would definitely say it's one
of the best ones i've had since i've
been in the nfl for sure
how often do you practice making a
one-hand catch because ideally you want
to go two hands but do you practice that
one-handed catch and you in case you
find yourself in a spot where you only
have the option to try to catch with one
hand
um i think uh
i think everyone likes to play around
with the one-handed catches when you're
just when you're just playing catch in
the backyard uh that's that's really the
only time i practice it i always try and
get two hands on on the ball every
chance that i can get just to secure it
uh because the
percentages for one-handed catches are
are pretty low i would assume um
but i it's uh it in my mind it's hard to
practice that because it's always it's
always something that's
an instinctual move you never you never
want to go up
with just one hand to catch a football
it's always kind of last second you have
to reach for it it's out of your uh
the two-hand uh radius so it's here
you're trying to grab it um
stretch over stretch to kind of get it
it's uh it's hard for it's hard to
practice um gauging something like that
do you make that catch yes or no without
the glove
um
i would say no not this one this one i
uh i probably wouldn't have caught
without a glove i it got stuck on my
glove there for a second which gave me
another chance to uh to grab it with my
hands so i think i think the gloves
definitely help shout out to nike i
appreciate you guys for that one
well and we hear about the gloves from
time to time at one point the nfl was
thinking about trying to make the gloves
less effective and then somebody
realized wait we want guys to be
catching these passes it's more exciting
when they catch them and when they don't
but how how helpful is it really to have
those gloves that that seem to want to
stick to anything that comes their way
um obviously i love them i mean i think
it's uh i think it's definitely
something that's that's made the game a
whole lot more fun to watch there's a
few catches out there um that i think
without gloves you're you're not seeing
guys make these plays uh but at the same
time you know it's uh
it's something that the games that's
grown with the game and sure enough
technology is taking the game to another
level
what's the best word that you would use
to describe the current kansas city
chiefs offense
um
man i would say the first word that
comes on my mind is exciting uh it's
it's just it's overall it's it's fun man
it's a it's a fun offense to play in uh
everyone's
everyone's loving this the success that
everyone everybody else is having um i
mean nine players have gotten in the end
zone just on the offensive side of the
ball and it's uh it's a blast seeing
guys go out there and have the success
that they are
there was some sound that was captured
week two at pittsburgh tyree kill and
chris connelly on the sidelines talking
about how much easier the offense is
this year with offensive coordinator
eric b enemy and from an outsider's
perspective wait it's still andy reid's
offense how much though has the offense
changed with matt nagy being now the
head coach that bears and eric the enemy
taking over as the offensive coordinator
um i think the biggest difference is the
mentality uh coach b enemy brings a
a fierce um
aggressive mentality to the offense
kind of a gritty uh
punch in the mouth type of type of
mindset and i think that has rubbed off
on everybody um from pat throwing the
ball aggressively downfield
the play calling is is is a little bit
more aggressive and sure enough
everybody getting the ball has been uh
has been a kind of a a north
runner there there's not too much
running sideways it's everybody's
getting downhill uh trying to finish the
finish the play in the end zone
you know you were with us last year when
patrick mahomes was the backup to alex
smith and you mentioned that patrick
mahomes is doing some incredible things
in practice we didn't get a chance to
see any of it until week 17 last year
we've seen it in dramatic ways the first
three weeks of the regular season what
growth have you seen in him from last
year to this year that makes these
performances to you not a surprise
um just his confidence you could see his
confidence grow from uh from the
preseason last year to the preseason
this year
how he goes about the play calling
we understand as a unit where coach reid
and coach bienami want
these plays to where the successes of
these plays and why he's calling them
the intentions of the play caller it's
uh and it's just overall fun fun
experience knowing that you know we have
so many guys that can make plays on the
offense
it's uh it's definitely something that
uh we're excited to see where this thing
can go
pat told me a story back in august about
playing t-ball when he was a kid and he
broke a kid's glasses throwing it from
short to first so the rules were changed
that he had to roll the ball to first
base had there been any complaints
practice or in games from you or any of
your teammates that hey pat take take a
little bit off of that you don't need to
zip it quite as hard as you are
no no we're letting pat do his things
we'll adjust to him
you got to let the quarterback be as
comfortable as he needs to be
back there in the pocket and however he
wants to get that ball to us so we got
to be ready for it
is this the most talented team you've
been on so far
without a doubt without a doubt i mean
there's a there's not a thought in my
mind that goes by that this is the the
best
team in terms of talent especially on
the offensive side of the ball um the
offensive line has been together for
three plush years they're they they work
unbelievable together the communication
right there is huge um on top of that i
mean the the skill set that we have is
is through the roof i mean we got
in my mind the fastest offense in the
league with tyreke and sammy uh chris
conley demarcus robinson i mean the list
goes on d'anthony thomas um guys can
flat out roll and it's uh
it makes it easy on the on the run game
because the safeties are playing deeper
and then
vice versa when we get the leading
rusher in the league the the ball at the
end of the game i mean he just punishes
teams
last year 5-0 start became six and six
it still worked out with the division
title but this year at 3-0 how do you
guard against a repeat of last year
where the team hit that pothole in the
middle of the season
um
i think the the biggest thing is uh
keeping the mentality uh the aggressive
mentality the the mentality of we can't
be stopped uh where we're out here to
to kind of you know smell blood we would
put us
put our foots on guys next when uh when
we can and um and go out there and just
will our way into victories uh i think
last year it got a little uh shaky
towards the end of games you know
finishing games finishing drives with
with seven on the offensive side
um and uh defensively stopping guys from
from getting seven points maybe maybe
getting them to only have three points
once it gets down in the red zone you
know it's a it's a
overall mentality of finishing games
finishing drives finishing plays uh for
the guys next year
has your brother jason kelsey the eagles
center is he put on his super bowl wing
ring and like waved it around in your
face and taunted you with it yet
he has not the only ring he's waved
around in front of me is his wedding
ring that's the only one i haven't seen
the super bowl ring up close yet
why why haven't you not seen it don't
you want to see it don't you want to get
your hands on it
i'll get i'll get my hands on my own i
think i i was in tears and of joy for
him when he finally got one last year um
for for a guy to to start off as a
walk-on linebacker at the university of
cincinnati to meet the
to to get to the peak of the mountain
and that's to win a super bowl in the
nfl i think uh his his career has
been motivational to not only myself but
a lot of people in this world i think
it's uh it's cool to see
how much does the fact that he's gotten
his ring travis how much does that
motivate you day in and day out to do
everything you need to do studying film
hydrating diet working out all the
things that maybe you'd be tempted to
say i don't need to do this today but
how much more locked in are you
as a result of motivation that comes
from seeing your brother get a super
bowl ring
it definitely weighs it weighs in for
sure and it's uh it's it makes me just a
little bit more competitive but i
promise you man i've been uh i've been
trying to live the the right way and and
do this thing the right way since i've
gotten here just because i'm i've i've
been hungry to get that ring ever since
i've got to the nfl
have you allowed yourself to consider
what kind of a suit you would wear to
the parade to one other brother and the
contraption that he had on
not at all i just want to get there
first i worry about the parade when we
win one
next place you're getting to is denver
on monday night any special preparation
that you do going to play at altitude in
that environment against one of your top
rivals
just a mindset know that it's gonna get
a little uncomfortable you're gonna get
tired and uh there's no
dancing around that it's uh it's mile
high for a reason and it's it's one of
the hardest places to play in the nfl
because of the
one the atmosphere but two the uh
they always have they are they're always
out to swing on you man they're they
throw one of the best punches in the nfl
um especially on defense their their
defense is always top tier in the league
so it's uh we know we got our hands full
every single time we play a division
rivalry especially against the denver
broncos
you know when the offense is clicking
the way it is and there's big plays and
there's you know there's still only one
football how hard is it to keep everyone
happy with the reps they get the touches
they get and the opportunities they get
to to score points and add big yardage
um i think it's easy when you're winning
um it can get it can get a little shaky
when uh when you're not winning i
remember going through it last year the
the five losses man it was uh
it was it was tough it was tough to kind
of keep the spirits high on the team um
keep everyone happy and um
sure enough uh right now we're winning
we're going to try and keep that thing
going but at the same time we've
learned a lot from what happened last
year and uh we're going to try and
eliminate any changes of it happening
this year
you know we've all been praising patrick
mahomes and for good reason all season
long give me one thing from your
perspective that you think he needs to
work on to become an even better player
than he's been
i mean the guys the guy's playing lights
out right now there's not much i could
say uh
i guess the only thing uh is
just making sure he can
he can fully pronounce the plays that's
about it that's in the huddle his voice
gets a little raspy especially in a loud
stadium it gets tough to kind of
understand what he's saying but uh
outside of um calling the plays i mean
the guys is he's going to keep
developing into one of the best
quarterbacks this league scene
how big of a concern is it last one for
you that uh as defenses see more and
more of what you're doing they're going
to have more film more clues more tells
more tendencies more ideas for shutting
him down
um you know that's that's where we rely
on uh coach andy reid and coach eric
bienemy especially on the offensive side
of the ball just um
teams are going to try and start
scheming us up and it's uh i think the
coaches have done unbelievable job with
throwing uh the personnel all over the
field uh giving guys great match-ups and
uh great indicators for pat back in the
uh in the pocket to be able to know
where he wants to go with the football
and um you know that's where we rely on
uh our
one of the greatest coaches ever play
this game coach reed is going to develop
a scheme uh to where it's going to be
hard to try and figure out what we're
going to do with the wall
you know i said last one but i got one
more on coach reed what have you noticed
from him this year as the team has been
excelling because he's seen it before
and he's seen how it can go
happy restrained where what's what's
been your read on his demeanor
i think we've all just been uh through
the roof excited and uh and ecstatic
about where we are i mean it's uh nobody
kind of i don't want to say nobody
expected this we set very high
expectations for ourselves but at the
same time we um we all came out ready to
work ready to go after it and i think uh
that's the biggest thing that coach reed
does well is that he he's going to
challenge you every single week to not
only get better but to uh to go out
there and and play for each other and
come away with a victory which are their
victories are hard to come by in the nfl
hey i can say this since i'm rarely
right i expected it because for me it
was the throw that patrick mahomes made
in the preseason last year on the run
got hit in the mouth 50 yards on a line
i mean
what was the moment when you saw this
kid and said wow we got something here
ah man you want to say that it was uh
that it happened a few times in practice
uh the throws that he made the the kind
of test in the waters testing his arm
see if his arm strength was he was
capable of making these throws um but i
really i didn't i didn't see it until
the the first touchdown pass to tyrique
i mean it was uh it was a it was a run
pass option he pulled he pulled it out
of kareem hunt's hands and he just threw
a dart to uh
to
uh tyreek hill and tyra killed did did
what tyra killed does best not to take
it to the house but it's um just to see
him
recognize the defense make a read get
the ball out quick and uh and in a
window that was very tight i think that
was um that was a
that was the point in time where i was
like all right it's the real deal all
the talking's over all the hope and the
expectations are over this uh this
dude's the real deal and uh we're we're
gonna we're gonna have our hands full
trying to trying to go out there and
make plays for them
well travis has been fun to watch we uh
thank you for some of your time he's the
bearded old spice guy check everything
out about the new old spice beard care
collection at amazon.com travis look
forward to talking to you again soon
i appreciate you for having us
you